welcome back well I'm going to show you
the last two logarithm properties now so
this one and and I always found this one
to be in some ways the most obvious one
but don't feel bad if it's not obvious
maybe we'll take a little bit of
introspection and I encourage you to
really experiment with all these
logarithm properties because that's the
only way that you'll really learn them
and the point of math isn't just to pass
the next exam or to get an A on the next
exam the point of math is to understand
math and so you can actually apply it in
life later on and not have to relearn
everything every time so the next
logarithm property is if I have a times
the logarithm base B of c5 a times this
whole thing that that equals that equals
logarithm base B of C to the a power
fascinating so let's see if this works
out so let's say if I have I don't know
three times logarithm base 2 of 8 so
this property tells us that this is
going to be the same thing as logarithm
base 2 of 8 to the third power and
that's the same thing well that's the
same thing as well we could figure it
out but so let's see what this is three
times log base what's the log base 2 of
8 I the reason why I kind of hesitated
the second it goes because every time I
want to figure something out I want to
use log and exponential rules kind of to
do it so I'm trying to avoid that but
anyway going back so so what is this log
bit 2 to what power is 8 well 2 to the
third power is 8 right so that's 3 and
we have this 3 here so 3 times 3 so this
thing right here should equal 9 if this
equals 9 then we know that this property
works at least
this example you don't know if it works
for all examples and for that maybe
you'd want to look at at the proof we
have in the other videos but that's kind
of a you know more advanced topic but it
you the important thing first is just to
understand how to use it so let's see
what is 2 to the 9th power well it's
going to be some large so actually I
know what it is it's a it's 256 because
we just in the last video we figured out
to the 8th was equal to 256 and so to
the 9th it should be 512 so this so 2 to
the 9th should be 512 so if 8 to the 3rd
is also 512 then then we are correct
right because log base 2 of 512 is going
to be equal to 9 right
well it's 8 to the third it's 64 time
right 8 times 8 squared is 64 so 8 cubed
so let's see 4 times 2 is 3 6 times a it
looks like it's 512 correct and there
are other ways you could have done it
because you know you could have said 8
to the third is the same thing as 2 to
the 9th how do we know that well 8 to
the third is equal to 2 to the third to
the third right I just rewrote 8 and we
know from our exponent rules that 2 to
the third to the third is the same thing
as to the 9 and actually it's this
exponent property where you can multiply
when you take something to exponent then
take that to an exponent and you can
essentially just multiply the exponents
that's the exponent property that
actually leads to this logarithm
property but I'm not going to dwell on
that too much in this presentation
there's a whole video on kind of proving
it a little bit more formally the next
logarithm property I'm going to show you
and then I'll review everything and
maybe do some examples this is probably
the single most useful logarithm
property if you are a calculator addict
and I'll show you why so let's say I
have log log log base
B of a is equal to log base C of a
divided by log base C of B now why is
this a useful property if you are
calculator addict well let's say you go
to class and there's a quiz the teacher
says week you can use your calculator
and using your calculator I want you to
figure out the log base 17 of 357 and
you will scramble and look for the log
base 17 button on your calculator and
not find it because there is no log base
17 number a button on your calculator
you'll probably either have a log button
or you'll have an Ln button and just so
you know the log button on your
calculator is probably base 10 and your
Ln number your Ln a button on your
calculator is going to be base e for
those of you who aren't familiar with
you don't worry about it but it's you
know 2.71 something something it's a
number it's nothing you know that it's
an amazing number but we'll talk more
about that in a future presentation but
so so there's only two bases you have on
your calculator so if you want to figure
out another base logarithm you use this
property so if you if you're given this
on an exam you can very confidently say
oh well that is just the same thing as
you would have to switch to your yellow
color in order to act with confidence
log base let's say we could do either E
or 10 but you could say that's the same
thing as log base 10 of 357 divided by
log base 10 of 17 so you literally could
just say you know type in 357 into your
calculator and press the log button
you're going to get by modal BAM then
you know you can clear it or if you do
not use parentheses and you can't get
you can do that but you say you know you
press type 70 in your calculator press
the log button you go to member them and
they just divide them and you get your
answer so this is a super useful
property for for
calculator addicts and and once again
I'm not going to go into a lot of depth
of how this this one to me it's the most
useful but it doesn't it's not it
doesn't completely fall it does fall out
of obviously of the exponent properties
but it it's hard for me to describe the
intuition simply so you probably want to
watch the proof on it if you don't
believe why this happens but anyway with
all of those aside this is probably the
one you're going to be using the most in
everyday life
I still use this in my in my job so you
know the logarithms are useful let's do
some let's do some examples so let's see
let's just let's just rewrite a bunch of
things in simpler forms so if I wanted
to write I don't know the log base two
of the square root of mmm let me think
of something of 32 divided by the
divided by the cube divided nihilistic
the square root divided by the square
root of eight how can I rewrite this so
it's reasonably not messy well let's
think about this this is the same thing
this is equal to if I move vertically or
horizontally but I'll move vertically
this is the same thing as the log base
two of 32 over the square root of eight
to the one-half power right and we know
from our logarithm properties the third
one we learned that that is the same
thing as one half times the logarithm
logarithm of 32 divided by the square
root of eight right I just took the
exponent and made that the coefficient
on the entire thing and we learned that
in the beginning of this video and now
we have a little quotient here right
logarithm of 32 divided by logarithm of
square root of eight well we can use our
other logarithm let's keep the one half
that's going to equal whoops parentheses
logarithm
I forgot my base logarithm base 2 of 32
- right because this isn't a quotient -
the logarithm base 2 of the square root
of 8 right let's see well here once
again we have a square root here so we
could say that this is equal to 1/2
times log base 2 of 32 - this is 8 to
the one-half which is the same thing as
1/2 log base 2 of 8 we learned that
property in the beginning presentation
and then if we want we can distribute
this original one-half and this equals
1/2 log base 2 of 32 minus 1/2 minus 1/4
it's going to distribute that 1/2 minus
1/4 log base 2 of 8 this is 5 halves -
this is 3 3 times 1/4 minus 3/4 or 10
fourths minus 3/4 is equal to 7/4 I
probably made some rhythmic arithmetic
errors but you get the point see you
soon